ฮะโอเคสวัสดีค่ะครูอัตติน่าสวัสดีครับครู
ah สวัสดีครับนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะน้องผมมา
ว้าวเกมอีกแล้วที่ไหนที่ช่อง com  Free
and  Small ไทยแล้ววันนี้โอเคข้างบนข้าง
คอมเพลนซุปเปอร์ไทยนะครับ
ครูอาร์ทตี้ขาวอันนี้เฮาเจอกันวันอะไรคะ
อ๋อวันนี้เราเจอกันวันเสาร์ครับขอเจอกัน
วันเสาร์ให้เขาวันนี้วันเสาร์อาทิตย์เท่า
ไหร่คะวันเสาร์วันที่
18 นี้ครับหาใช่ครับวันเสาร์ที่ 18
แล้วเดือนอะไรคะอ๋อเดือนนี้เดือนนี้เดือน
ธันวาคมทัพหาและเมื่อ
ธันวาคมชายใช่แล้วเดือนธันวาคมปีพตทอะไร
แล้วค่ะปีพต
2564 ครับอ่าชาญ
564 ค่ะถูกต้องครับแล้วปีคศเท่าไหร่คะมี
คอส.ต.ต.ปีนี้ปี
2010  21 ครับ 2 คัน 21 นะคะได้ครับมัน
วันนี้วันเสาร์เมื่อวานคะวิวรรณอะไรคะอ๋อ
วันนี้วันเสาร์เมื่อวานเมื่อวานนี้ครับ
เมื่อวานเมื่อวานวันศุกร์ครับเพราะวัน
ศุกร์ใส่งานเมื่อวานวันศุกร์
แล้ววันศุกร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะแต่เมื่อวาน
วันศุกร์อาวันที่นี่ครับวันที่ 17 ครับ
เอาวันที่ 17  5 ให้แล้ววันศุกร์ที่ 17
วันนี้วันเสาร์เมื่อวานวันศุกร์พรุ่งนี้
วันอะไรคะอ๋ออ๋อพรุ่งนี้
ค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันที่
อ้าววันอะไรซึ่งให้วันอะไรอะไรวันนี้วัน
ส่วนเต๋า
พรุ่งนี้ที่วัน
อาทิตย์ครับวันอาทิตย์พรุ่งนี้วันอาทิตย์
วันที่
19 ถูกต้องครับใจเขา
ก็วันนี้วันเสาร์ครู Arty กับครูเอ๋มาคุย
กันให้เวลา
ตอนนี้ตอนนี้กี่โมงตอนนี้ 9 โมงคะห๊า 9
โมง 20 นาทีครับ
9:20 นๆใช่ครับข้าวโมง 20 น
กูอะตี้วันนี้นะครูเอกคิดคิดคิด
ๆกู Arty ครูเอ๋เนี่ยเป็นคนไทยชายเป็นไป
หายอ้าวเป็นคนอะไรดีนักเรียนที่ฟังครู 2
คนอยู่อ่ะคอมเม้นท์บอกครูด้วยนักเรียนคน
ประเทศอะไรนะคะใช่ครับประเทศอะไรขวดอี้
อยากรู้หน้ามักเรียนไม่เข้าใจประเทศกู
Arty มีแผนที่โลกมั้ยอ้ะแขนที่โลกใช่ไหม
ครับแผนที่โลกโอ้นี่นี่ / ท้องโลกแค่
แผนที่โลกประเทศไทยอยู่ตรงไหนคะ S ไทย
อยู่ตรงนี้มีเขาประเทศไทย
อ้าประเทศไทยอยู่ตรงนี้
โอ้โห
ประเทศไทยควรตีแดงๆเปลี่ยนสีแดงนี่ประเทศ
ไทยอยู่ตรงนี้ใช่
อ่าแล้วที่สีเขียวใกล้ๆประเทศไทยประเทศ
อะไรคะสีเขียวใกล้ๆประเทศไทยตรงนี้ค่ะตรง
นี้ประเทศพม่าครับประเทศเมียนมาร์เนาะอ่า
หอมเมียนมา 5  Way
เปลี่ยนชื่อเป็นเมียน้อยอะไรๆ
rr&b อินเดียอยู่ตรงไหนคะเทศอินเดียนี้
ครับประเทศอินเดียอยู่นี่ประเทศอินเดีย
ถ้าเมียฮ่าๆได้ครับห๊ะฉีดดีอ่ะ
อินเดียสีฟ้าเนาะ c5i ครับสีฟ้าอินเดียสี
ฟ้าครับ
รักสีน้ำเงินใหญ่ๆประเทศอะไรคะ
สีน้ำเงินใหญ่นี้ประเทศจีนครับขอประเทศ
จีนมาข้ามประเทศจีนคนไทยคนไทยเรียกจีน
อาก้นต่างชาติเรียก China
ครับคนไทยเรียกจีน
จีนนะคะอ่ะอ่ะ
ลาวา
R8 เทศาาาเกาหลีตรงไหนเกาหลี
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
เก๋อยู่ตรงไหนครับเป็นเนอะตัวที่ประเทศ
ญี่ปุ่นประเทศญี่ปุ่นอยู่นี่นะครับนี่
ญี่ปุ่นม.นี้ครับประเทศเกาหลีโอเคตัวที่
เห็นแล้ว
อ้าประเทศเกาหลีเกาหลีนะคะสวัสดีขยาย
เกาหลีนี้ญี่ปุ่นประเทศญี่ปุ่นมีประเทศ
เดาหลี
ประเทศจีนประเทศกินดีอ่ะ
นะฮะจริงๆโลกมีประเทศประเทศประเทศมากๆ
เนาะ
เรื่องประเทศครู Arty คู๋พูดฤทธิ์หน่อยนะ
คะครับผมว่าวันนี้นักเรียนอ้อประเทศครู
Arty ครูเอ๋เป็นคนไทยใช่อยู่ประเทศถ่ายๆ
ครับคนไทยอยู่ประเทศไทยตอนนี้ 2,000  21
ครู Arty อยู่ประเทศประเทศไทยไปครับพี่
เก๋อยู่ประเทศไทย
ประเทศไทยปีนี้ปีหน้าไม่รู้เราต่อไปไม่
รู้ไม่รู้หรอไม่รู้
รัฐและก็นักเลงก็เห็นน้องอันนี้เป็น
แผนที่โลกโลกครับแต่ที่โลก
ที่นี่เนี่ยครู Arty ครูเอ๋เนี่ยชอบชอบนะ
ชอบไปเที่ยว
ไปเที่ยวรีบนะเอกคิดคู๋ยังไม่เคยไปนะเคย
ไปครับแต่ครูเอกคิดอินเดียอินเดียอินเดีย
ห่า
คิดอยากไปไปนะอ๋อโอเคกูเอกก็คิดเวียดนาม
Vietnam เวียดนามอยู่ตรงไหนคะอ๋ออ๋อ
เวดนามมีครับเวียดนามอยู่
อยู่ตรงนี้เมื่ออยู่เมตรนามเวียดนามสี
อะไรครับครูเอ๋สีชมพูไหมอ่ะ
ใช่ๆเวียดนามสีชมพูเดี๋ยวกลัวตีนลบอันนี้
เอาก่อนนะจะได้มองเห็นชัดๆนี่
เวียดนามเวียดนามน้ำเอกกะที่โอ้ยวิทย์นาม
คู๋ชอบเวียดนามอ๋อ
ชอบอินเดียก็ชอบอินเดียด้วย
และพระเอกจะชอบจีน on ชอบจีนวอล
เกาหลีขอขอบเกาหลีด้วยโอ้วชอบที่ไหนบาส
ชอบอ่าสกอตแลนด์
สกอตแลนด์สกอตแลนด์อยู่ทั้งไหนอยู่ด้านบน
อยู่ได้อยู่นะคะโน้ตไปอีกแล้วโอเคแล้วโป้
นักเรียนครูเอ๋ชอบเอเชียเท่านั้นเหรอขอ
มุมมีเพศชายชอบนะทุกประเภทอะติ๊ดชอบไหมคะ
อ้าควรตีก็ชอบชอบๆประเทศอ่ะใช้กับเอกก็
คิดนะกู Arty กูเอกชอบกูอีกนะคิดชอบเสื้อ
ผ้าขอ
เสื้อผ้า
ชุดแล้วบอกว่าชุดอ่ะคู๋เนี่ยชอบเพราะกู
อยากไปอินเดียอยากไปจีนจากไปสก็อตแลนด์
อยากไปฝรั่งเศส
อยากไปอเมริกาด้วย
แคนาดาไปแล้วเห็นอยากไปอยากไปแล้วก็ไปดู
ไปดูไปดูชุดใช่ไหมครับไปดูชุดชุดประจำอา
นาจขอชุดประจำชาติของของประเทศ
จีนดียาใช่ไหมอ๋อ
ประเทศจีนด้วย
เวียดนามประเทศเวียดนาม
ของผู้ทั้งหมดอย่างเช่นก่อนทั้งโลกเลยใช่
ไหมทางโลกคู๋ชอบชุดประจำชาติเดี๋ยวโคโย
ตี้พานักเรียนไปดูชุดประจำชาติวอตี้มีมี
รูปชุดประจำชาตินะมาดูฐานอ้าใช่ค่ะดู
กันหาเท่ห์อ่าโอเคชุดแรกชุดที่ 1 โอเค
อะไรคะไปประเทศประเทศญี่ปุ่นครับ
ญี่ปุ่นาไปญี่ปุ่นอยู่ตรงนี้ญี่ปุ่น
ประเทศที่ครับอ้ามีข่าวประเทศญี่ปุ่นนี้
เป็นก็มีผู้ชายกับผู้หญิงอ้ามีผู้ชายมี
ผู้หญิงอ่ะผู้ชายครับผู้ชายทำไมคะอ่ะผู้
ชาคนที่ใส่ชุดประจำชาติญี่ปุ่นนายใส่สี
อะไรคะสีดำครับนี้มี
ข้างล่างควรตีคิดคิดว่าสีเทา
[เพลง]
ami อ๋อโอเคสีเทาเหมือนที่กูเอ๋ถืออยู่
นะครับเสียงเอากางเกงสีเทา
หือ
แล้วก็ผู้หญิงเป็นชุดสีอะไรคะอ้าผู้หญิง
ใส่ชุดโว่สีสีแดงสีแดง
นะครับ Mini ลายมีลายก็ได้ครับอ่ะมีลาย
ดอกไม้นี่ดอกไม้ลุนนี่มีนกตรงนี้มีเป็นนก
นกนก
แล้วก็มีข้างบนที่หัวผู้หญิงมีข้างบนตรง
นี้เรียก
ม่วงหน้าม่วงใช่ครับหมูภาษาไทยหมวกภาษา
ญี่ปุ่น 2 คนไม่รู้นะคะคือรู้คนญี่ปุ่น
ถ้าดูพิมพ์บอกครูด้วยนะคะเรียกว่าอะไร
ครับ
[เพลง]
จากครูเอ๋รู้กู Arty ชอบนี้เนี่ยครับ
กิโมโนขอ
โชว์กี้โมโน
ชุดกิโมโนโอเคแปลเป็นชุดกิโมโนสำหรับแต่ง
งานอ๋ออ๋อสำหรับแต่งงานๆมีงานผู้ชายกับ
ผู้หญิงแต่งงานน่ะ
ดีๆตื่นๆแต่งงาน
สวยนะ
กูอะตี้มีชุดกิโมโนอีกใช่ไหมคู๋นะมโนาชุด
นี้สวยมากชุดนี้อ่ะเราไปดูไปดูเป็นสี
สวยสวยๆไหม
ซุปเปอร์โมเดลสวย
คนนี้คนนี้ครัวตี้เคยเห็นกูที่เกรงแล้ว
เห็นเคยเห็นที่ไหนคะฮ่าๆใครครับเออคนนี้
นายครับมาใคร
นักเรียนใคร
ครูเอ๋ค่ะหาครูเอ๋เองเดี๋ยวตัวเองต้องใส่
ใส่แว่นใส่แว่นเธอคนนี้คนนี้ไม่ใส่แว่น
อ่ะอันนั้นครูเอ๋เวลาอายุเท่าไรอ่ะจนเจ็บ
ตั้งแต่ 3  9  10  41 ถ. 41 ไม่ใส่ไม่ใส่
แว่นไม่ใส่แว่นอ่ะ
ตอนนี้อายุไปว่าตอนนี้ค่ะ 13  5 แล้วก็
สาว 53 ไปแว่น k  a
s ชุดกิโมโน
ชนหัวรอขอชุดประจำชาติญี่ปุ่นใช่ไหมค่าย
ญี่ปุ่นเวลาใส่นะ
เป็นไงครับไม่ได้
ฮ่าๆกินไม่ได้ก็จะมีภาคแบบนี้สาระหาจะ
ครับแล้วจะรับ
อันนี้เป็นนั่งอยู่ข้างในใช่ไหมโอเคอ๋อ
ต้องไม่ต้องไปดูใช่รูปภาพข้างล่างภาพนี้
ไหมถ้าวันนี้ไม่มีมีร้านตรงนี้ใช่ไหมใช่
อ๋อเขาจะมีตัวนี้แล้วเขาก็รัดอ่ะ
หายใจเข้าหายใจออกเหนื่อยมาขอ
หายใจเข้าออกไม่ไม่ดีใช่ไหมไม่ดีเล่นแน่น
แน่นมากๆนะ
กินไม่ได้ฮ่าๆกินให้มีเดียวแนนบ้างแนน
โน้ะชุดญี่ปุ่นสวยสวยๆใส่แล้วกินไม่ได้
ต้องนั่งลง
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
สวยสวยๆ
เรามีครุฑประจำชาติประเทศอื่นอีกนะมีชุด
ประจำชาติทั่วประเทศอื่นครับ
ชุดที่นี่อย่าตีเราต้องปิดหน้านะคะ
เป็นชุดประเทศอะไรขอ 5
ขวดที่คิดคิดไม่รู้ไม่รู้ผู้ a หินใกล้ๆ
ประเทศไทยไม่ๆประเทศไทยควรตี้คิดว่าเออ
เวียดนามไหมครับอ้ามากเนี่ยเงียบตาม
งามงามใช้ครับ
เราไม่เห็นหน้านะกูอาชีพคิดว่ากูเอ๊ะใส่
สีอะไรอันนี้มีครูเอ๋ด้วยหรอมีครู hu ให้
ดูหน้า a ใส่สีชมพูสีขาว
แอปปี่ม่วงแอร์
สีฟ้า
สีเขียวขาวใช่ฟิวส์ซื้อสีแดงสีอะไรครับ
เออสีขวดอีการ์ดสีเขียวๆค่ะขอ
กลัวตีกำลังจะเดาว่าชุดหมีใช่ไหมครับกูเอ
บอกแล้วกูอยากบอกว่าเอ๋ใส่ชุดออกคนนี้คน
นี้กูเองโอเคอ่าวายขอ
[เพลง]
พี่วิทย์นามพูดอะไรนักเรียนคอมเม้นข้าง
ล่างเนาะ
นักเรียนเวียดนามมีไหมคะอ้ามีนักเรียน
เวียดนามพูด
เรียกว่าชุดอะไรครับการชุดอะไรครับคุณนี้
คนไทยพูดเอาได๋เอาไหนนะโอเคเวียดนามพูด
เอาใหญ่เอ้าใหญ่อ๋อโอเคว่ะตี้ปาร์ตี้ไม่
พูดผู้ที่ไม่รู้
ไม่รู้ฮ่าๆก็เป็นชุดประจำชาติเวียดนาม
ชุดประจำชาติเวียดนามโอเค
ขับอ่ะมีไหมอีกนะนี่อีกหรอคะไม่มีอีกครับ
อีกเดี๋ยวเราไปดูมาประเทศนี้เนี่ยชุด
ประเทศต่อไปครูเอ๋อยากไปประเทศนี้
คุยอยากไปกินดีอ่ะนี้
ใจครับที่สุดสิสีอะไรอ่ะควรอ่านมีสีชมพู
สีชมพูครู Arty ก็สีชมพู
ใช่ครับเลือกครูแอ๊ดตี้สีชมพูแช่ครับครู
เอ๋สีชมพูเหมือนกันอันนี้ก็สีชมพูใช่ครับ
อินเดียคู๋ชอบอ๋อ
โอเคทำไมครูเอ๋ชอบชุดอินเดียครับเวลากู
เอ๋เด็กๆครูเอกชอบดูซีรี่ย์อินเดีย
เบียร์ขอ
ได้อยากได้ชุดอินเดียชุดอินเดียเราพูดว่า
ชุดสาหรีนะอ๋ออ๋อชุดส่าหรีควรที่รู้จัก
รู้จักชุดส่าหรีาหลี
are  you  a มีมีผ้าตัวที่เป็นสาหรีนะ
อ๋อนี่ด้วยใช่ไหมมีผ้าส่าหรีโอเคอ๋อเห
รอ
ดู
ภาพสวยๆ
ใส่ไม่ได้ใส่ไม่เสร็จล่าดูดูดู
เท่านั้น
ยินดี
อยากไปอินเดียเกย์
[เพลง]
อินเดีย
อตี้มีชุดอินเดียนะแล้วอ้าชุด
ประเทศอะไรอีกเดี๋ยวเราไปประเทศล้ใกล้ๆ
ใกล้ๆๆๆไวๆๆๆๆๆๆมาใช้ครับโรบล่ะคะใช่ครับ
เดี๋ยวเราไปที่ประเทศนี้ครับอ่ะกูเอ๋คิด
ว่าประเทศอะไรครับประเทศนี้เพียงเพศอะไร
ครับเวลาฝรั่ง
อ๋อ
เดี๋ยวนะ
ครับคิดๆห่า
แอร์วายอร่อย
อวยชัย
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
สต็อดแล้วหรอสปอร์ตแลนด์ไปขาว
สก๊อต Man ผู้ชายใส่กระโปรง
หรอหาใช้ครับผู้ชายใส่กระโปรง
มื้อ
ก็ครองๆประจำชาติของสก๊อตแลนด์แลนด์โอเค
พูดชุดอะไรไม่รู้นะเออว่าตีก็ไม่รู้ไม่
รู้ไม่รู้ชื่อคนไทยก็พูดชุดประจำชาติหนา
คะแปลกประจำชาติสกอตแลนด์กูเขามีถุงที่
เราด้วยนะครับอ๋อใช่ครับมีถุงเท้า
หน้านี่ถุงเท้าถุงรองเท้า
หาถุงเท้าอยู่นี่แล้วก็รองเท้า
แล้วก็กลับเป๋ากระเป๋าตรงนี้นี่กระเป๋า
ให้ครับเป็นกระเป๋าก็ติ๊กคิดว่าคิดว่า
เป็นกระเป๋าคว้านะแล้วก็เสื้อเสื้อเสื้อ
หนึ่งสองสามอ้าวหนึ่งสองสาม
อาวุธที่คิดคิดคิดว่าอ่าที่สกอตแลนด์ดาว
หนาวๆใส่เสื้อหนึ่งสองสามสี่ตัวหนาวตาย
วันนี้ที่กรุงเทพฯก็หนาวนะหนาวเหรอครับ
ฮ่าๆโอเค Happy ไม่หนาวหรอว่ากลัวที่ไม่
หนาวเลยมันผู้ a หนาวหอคอยขออธิบายขวดตี
มันอ่ะ 28 องศานี่ครับ
ตอนนี้ 28 หน้าหนาวนะยี่สิบแปดหนาวกวนติว
สึก
นิดหน่อยนิดหน่อยร้อนนิดหน่อยโอเค
มันประมาณ 20-25 ขอ
ชุดประจำชาติ
ประเทศ and  hot แปลนะคะครับก็โอ้ยนี่ไง
ครับที่ในครับเป็นตัวกระโปรงเนี่ยคนไทย
พูดลายสก๊อตอ๋ออ๋อใช่ครับใช่ครับลายสก๊อต
ลายสก๊อตจะเป็นอ่าแบบนี้แบบนี้แบบนี้อะไร
ก็มีแบบนี้อ้านี่ลายสก๊อตคนไทยพูดลาย
สก๊อตนามาจากชุดประจำชาติสก๊อตแต่อันนี้
ไม่ไม่ใช่ลายสก๊อตก.ยจะได้ไม่ใช่
มีอีกไหมคะนี้มีอีกไหมมีอีกครับมีอาบอาบ
ชาตินี้ครูเอกก็อยากไปประเทศนี้ในประเทศ
ที่ยายมาก
ใช่ครับ
รู้แล้ว
ชัดจีนใช่ไหมคะถ้าใส่เหงาประเทศจีนใหญ่
มากแต่เขามากๆจะชุดเล็กมากๆ
เล็กมากเลยเพลงชอบมากๆกู Arty ชุดคนไทย
พูดกี่เพ้าชุดกี่เพ้า
สีอะไรคะภู Arty กี่เพ้ามีชุดนี้ชุดนี้สี
แดงครับสีแดงได้ครับแล้วชุดนี้ครับอ่าชุด
เอาสีชมพู
นะผู้หญิงถืออะไรคะอ้าผู้หญิงถือพัดพัด A
Plus ราคาในงานรองเท้าสูงมากน่าใช้ครับ
รองเท้าสูงอาอีกรองเท้าสูงไหมครับอ้าสูง
มากสูงได้ครับ
ชุดกี่เพ้ากูเอกก็ชอบ
ใส่ไม่ได้
ทำไมใส่ไม่ได้ครับใส่แล้วกินอาหารไม่หนอ
กับ
เอกกินก่อนกินก่อนแล้วค่อยใส่
ก็กินแล้วก็ใส่ไว้ได้
A มีกี่ Powder
ไม่รู้มีชุดกี่เพ้าแต่ใส่ละ 10 ไว้ด่า
ใส่ไม่ได้ไม่
และได้มอบ
มหาไม่เป็นไรแต่สวยชุดกี่ภาวะเนี่ยต้องขา
ขาตีตีตรงขานี่ไหมคะขาหนาเค้าสวย
ขาสวยหน้าขา
S ครูเอ๋เอ๋เรามีทูธ of ประเทศเอ่อ
อินเดียเวียดนามญี่ปุ่น
อ่ะสกอตแลนด์จีนแล้วแล้วมีชุดของประเทศ
ไทยให้นักเรียนดูด้วยไหมครับอีกนะดีไหม
อ่าอ่ะเราไปดูชุดของประเทศไทยกัน
ผู้อยากดูชุดของอันนี้นี้ของประเทศจีนสวย
ไหมครับสวยค่ะสวยโอเคกวนตีแค่ไทยก็ต้อง
สวยมากก็ต้องสวยมากฮ่าๆโอ้มายไปดูประชุด
ของเทพไทย 5 ไหนครับนี่ไง
สวยมาก
ดูกี่เพ้าใหม่กินข้าวกี่เพ้าใช่ไหมครับ
นี่ครับกินข้าวอยู่นี่อันนี้กี่เพ้าสวยนะ
ครับอ่าชุดกีโมโนสู่สวย
r0 ใส่แล้วไอ้อาหารไม่ได้ขายสวยสวยกิน
อาหารได้มากๆ
อันนี้ชุดไทยชุดไทยชุดไทย
ประจำชาติของไทยเนี่ยน่ะมีมากๆนะคะหลาย
ชุดใช่ไหม
อันนี้เป็นคนแก่ท้อน
วันนี้ครัวตี้เคยเห็นนะเคยเห็นนะผัวที่จำ
ได้จำวันนี้ได้
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ได้ๆเขาดีจองได้ๆ
อะนักเรียนรู้แล้วคนนี้คนนี้ใครนักเรียน
รู้แหละ
เขียวชุดชุดที่คนนี้ใส่อ่ะเพื่อเนี่ยมี
อะไรนะคะ
ให้สีชมพูเห็นกัน
โอโอ้เหมือนกันชมพูน่าเชื่อเรียกว่าอะไร
คะขอเป็นเสื้อ
คอ
ก.ยกระเป๋าอาหารใช่ครับ
มีค่า
เสื้อคอกระเช้า wow
ฮะ
โอเคอะที่ซื้อทีที่รูปเขามีเสื้อยืดเสื้อ
ยืดเอาจริงทิ้งเวลาใส่เสื้อคอกระเช้าไม่
ต้องใส่เสื้อยืดๆไม่ต้องใส่และแต่ว่ากู
ไอ้ร้อนใช่ไหมร้อนไหม
ร้อนเลยนะใส่เสื้อไว้เสื้อยืดก่อนแล้วก็
ใส่ก็จะออกกะเช้าแต่แต่ว่ากู AI ไงจาก
เค้า 100% ฮ่าๆๆฮ่าๆๆ
เกย์แล้วมีเสื้ออะไรอีกครับ
น้าที่ข้างล่างเนี่ยไม่เป็นไม่ใช่เสื้อ
เป็นอันไหนๆนี้
โจงกระเบน
จองกระเบนอ่ะอ่าหนูโจรกระเบนเค้าเป็นชุด
ไทยใช่ไหมเป็น
เป็นกางเกง
โจงกระเบนจะขอ
ก็มีไม้เท้า R5 แบบนี้แบบนี้ใช่ไหมอ๋ออ๋อ
นี่ไงมีไม้เท้าตรงนี้อีกไม้เท้าใส่จูง
กระเบนนะเราก็เสื้อคอกระเช้าอ่ะชมประสาว
ราคาถ้าจะสวยๆหน่อยก็มีซื้อให้รู้สึกอะไร
เนี่ยเรื่องของออ
[เพลง]
บ่เคยเห็นชุดนี้ไหมอ่าถามว่านักเรียนเคย
เห็นเนาะอ้าๆชุดแบบนี้อ่ะเรียกเรียกอะไร
ครับ
ชุดไทยจักรีชุดไทยจากอ๋ออ๋อชุดไทยจักรี
ชุดไทยจักรีสวยอ่ะเนี่ยมีสไบตอนนี่สบาย
สบายมีใบยาวใบยาวลงมาอีกยาวลงมายาวก็มีมี
อ่าเรียกว่าผ้าซิ่นก็ได้ผ้าถูก็ได้ตรงนี้
มีตรงนี้เป็นผ้าซิ่นนะครับหรือผ้าถุง
เป็นผ้าเขาจะ
ขอจะยาวยาวใช่ครับเออ
แล้วมี.คอย่าขัดด้วยตรงนี้เป็นเข็มขัด
เข็มขัดถุงขรรค์หัตถ์
ถ้าค่าที่ห้อยออกมาตรงเนี้ยเขาเรียกว่า
หน้านาง
หน้านางด้วยเอาอยู่ตรงนี้อ๋อตรง c5 มีตรง
นี้ด้วยหน้านางสวยๆโอ้ยชุดสวยๆชุดไทยมี
สวยรวย
โอเคมีจริงๆค่ะ
อันนี้ชุดคนแก่
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
กลัวดิกลัวตีเคยเห็นแบบนี้ด้วยนิดเป็นชุด
ไทย ohec9d
[เพลง]
แม้กาลเวลาผู้หญิงอาบน้ำนานเท่านั้นแต่
แต่งหน้าแต่งงานใช่หรอใส่ชุดไทยบรมพิมาน
หัวว้าวโอเควันนี้เลยช่วยคุยไม่ใส่
กินข้าวไม่ได้อีกแล้วคู๋ใส่ชุดสวยกินข้าว
ไม่ได้ไปคอกระเช้าโอเคที่ 1 ได้ใช่ไหมขอ
กระเช้าอ่าโอเคค่ะวันนี้ใช่ครับวันนี้นัก
เรียนก็เข็นชุดประจำชาติหน้าใช่ครับของ
ของแต่ละประเทศราคาในเข่า
เรารีวิวอีก 1 ชั้นดีไหมคะน่าได้ครับชุด
กิโมโนกิโมโนกิโมโนนี่โดนออถูกต้องทำชุด
ประจำชาติญี่ปุ่นกิโมโนแต่ชุดต่อไปค่ะชุด
เขาใหญ่จุดเป่าใหญ่อะไรเนี่ยนามครับ
อาหารต่อไปค่ะอ้า
สาลีสีอะที่ประจำชาติประเทศอะไรคะอ้า
ประจำชาติอินเดียครับประเทศอินเดีย
ชุดต่อไปค่ะไม่รู้ชื่อ
ประจำชาติอะไร
สกอตแลนด์ครับโอเค
สกอตแลนด์ 5 กี่เพ้ากี่เพ้าอะไรคะ 5
ประจำประเทศจีนครับ
โอเค
โอเคอะไรก็ชุดนี้ชุดนี้สุดนี้อ้านี่ชุด
ไทยจักรีถ้าแล้วก็ชุดสุดท้ายครับชุดนี้
ชุดไทยบรมพิมานเชคอ่ะไข่ใช่ครับใช่ครับ
เวลาหมดแล้วใช่วันนี้เวลาหมดแล้วครับหมด
เป็นรานะครับนะคะนักเรียนนักเรียนดูฟัง
แล้วก็คอมเม้นท์มีรูปได้ไหมอ่ะชุดประจำ
ชาตินักเรียนชื่ออะไรก็ขอคอมเม้นบอกบอก
ครัวตี้บอกครูเอ๋น่าในคอมเม้นต์ได้แล้ว
เดี๋ยวคราวหน้าเรากลับมากลับมาเรียนภาษา
ไทยในช่องคอม pienza ไทยกันใหม่นะครับอ่า
วันนี้กลัวที่สวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋ครับผมโอเค
ค่ะอ่าตีเนียนบ๊ายบาย
ม.ค